after a violent mob attacked the u.s
capitol on january the 6th the biden
administration
made so-called domestic terrorism a top
priority
resources in fbi field offices have been
moved more federal lawyers employed to
prosecute cases
attorney general merrick garland says
it's the biggest threat facing america
in the fbi's view the top domestic
violent extremist threat comes from
racially or ethnically motivated violent
extremists
specifically those who advocated for the
superiority of the white race
in a statement president joe biden said
domestic terrorism caused by hatred
prejudice and other extremism is a stain
on the american soul
it goes against everything our country
strives for
garland was the federal prosecutor in
the oklahoma bombing
the biggest case of domestic terrorism
in u.s history
168 people died that was in 1995.
in recent years the number of attacks
has increased from the targeting of
members of congress by a left-wing
gunman at a baseball game
the shooting at the pulse nightclub in
orlando where 49 people died
and the car attack on anti-fascist
protesters in charlottesville and
virginia which killed a young woman
now the fbi plans to increase
intelligence sharing work with tech
companies to eliminate content that
could incite extremism
and work across government to identify
and root out
potential attackers or supporters even
in military and law enforcement
the national strategy is designed to
coordinate and provide a principled path
for the federal government's efforts to
counter
the heightened domestic terrorism threat
using all available tools
the trump white house was often
reluctant even to acknowledge the issue
of domestic terrorism
often comparing the threat from
right-wing extremists
to that of black lives matter protests
and antifa the anti-fascist group
even though intelligence reports said
that white supremacy was a key driver
of domestic terrorism this plan
acknowledges the elevated threat
and asks congress to find 100 million
dollars
to help fight it the justice department
led by garland is evaluating whether to
ask congress to pass
a specific law addressing what it
regards as domestic terrorism
they currently don't exist many
lawmakers believe
existing laws are enough alan fisher al
jazeera
the white house